>> WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION
OF HANNITY.
I SIT DOWN WITH MARK LEVINE FOR
AN ENTIRE HOUR.
HIS BOOK, "UNFREEDOM OF THE
PRESS."
WE'LL START AT THE NATION'S
FOUNDING, REMEMBERING THE ONCE
GREAT PRESS TRADITION IN AMERICA
AND HOW IT ENDED UP BECOMING
NOTHING MORE THAN AN EXTENSION
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ALL
THINGS LEFT WING.
WE'LL UNCOVER WHAT WENT WRONG,
HOW THE MEDIA FELL SO FAR SO
FAST.
WE'LL BE EXPOSING EVERY HOAX,
EVERY LIE, ALL OF THE B
BESPURGEMENT THIS MEDIA MOB HAS
DONE TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND DIVIDING THIS
COUNTRY.
FROM THE RUSSIAN DELUSION, AND
IGNORING THE BIGST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
WE'LL TAKE IT APART
PIECE-BY-PIECE AND EXPOSE HOW
THEY'VE ABANDONED THE FREEDOM OF
THE PRESS IN THIS COUNTRY
CHOOSING TO ACT AS NOTHING MORE
THAN PARTISAN HACKS.
CHOOSING TO PUT FAKE NEWS
NARRATIVES OVER FACTS FOR YEARS
AT A TIME.
CHOOSING OH TO SMEAR ANYONE AND
EVERYONE WHO DARES CALLS OUT
THEIR LACK OF ETHICS, THEIR LACK
OF OBJECTIVITY.
REMEMBER THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA
MOB AND THE BIGGEST NAMES ON THE
LEFT NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD GET
TO THIS POINT.
NEVER THOUGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULD PULL OFF WHAT WAS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST POLITICAL UPSETS OF
AMERICAN HISTORY AND DELIVER
SUCCESS AFTER SUCCESS, RECORD
AFTER RECORD, HELPING THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF THIS
COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE MIGHT BE LEADING THE
REPUBLICAN TICKET.
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T MEAN THAT.
>> WHICH OF THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES HAS THE BEST CHANCE?
>> OF THE DECLARED ONES, RIGHT
NOW, DONALD TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE].
>> MR. TRUMP, ANSWER YOUR CALL
FOR POLITICAL HONESTY, I WANT TO
SAY, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT, ALL RIGHT?
IT'S BEEN FUN.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL GO DOWN
AS PERHAPS THE WORST PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES,
EXCLAMATION
POINT,@REALDONALDTRUMP.
WELL,@REALDONALDTRUMP, AS LEAST
I WILL GO DOWN AS A PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: AND A FAILED ONE AT
THAT.
REMEMBER HOW THEY REACTED THE
NIGHT HE WON THE ELECTION,
NOVEMBER 10, 2016.
DONALD TRUMP EXIT POLLS SHOWED
TRUMP DIDN'T WIN A SINGLE STATE.
ALL THROUGH THE NIGHT, THE MOOD
STARTED TO CHANGE.
IT BECAME COMPLETELY UNHINGED.
ACTUALLY, HYSTERIA BROKE OUT.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER.
>> AMERICA IS CRYING TONIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH OF
AMERICA, BUT A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION, I MEAN LITERALLY
CRYING.
THIS IS A SADnd THIS, IS A
MOURNING MOMENT FOR THOSE
PEOPLE.
AND IT IS A MOMENT FILLED WITH
FEAR, FILLED WITH FEAR.
>> OUR COUNTRY IS ABOUT TO FACE
A CRISES.
SO BUCKLE UP, YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS
YOU.
>> A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY THING
TO SAY IF YOU HAVE A SON IN THE
MARINE CORPS AND THAT YOU DON'T
TRUST THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
PEOPLE IN THE MILITARY DEFEND
THE INSTITUTIO
THE COSTITUTIO
THE CONSITUTIO
THE CONSTIUTIO
THE CONSTITUIO
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> THIS WAS A WHITE LASH.
THIS WAS A WHITE LASH AGAINST A
CHANGING COUNTRY.
IT WAS A WHITE LASH AGAINST A
BLACK PRESIDENT IN PART.
>> Sean: AND SADLY, SINCE THAT
NIGHT, THINGS HAVE GOTTEN WORSE.
THE LIBERAL LEFT WING PRESS
REFUSED TO HAVE ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY, ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
FAILURES.
NOW THEY'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON
WHAT IS A PSYCHOTIC ANTI-TRUMP
RAGE AND DESTROYING WHATEVER
CREDIBILITY THEY MAY HAVE EVER
HAD.
THIS IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLE OF
THEIR LOW LIGHTS.
>> IS THIS PRESIDENT TRYING TO
IMPERSONATE HUGO CHAVEZ,
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> YOU SAID TODAY, AMERICA
FIRST.
IT WAS NOT JUST A RACIAL
IDIOM -- I SHOULDN'T SAY A
HITLERIAN BACKGROUND TO IT.
>> TRUMP NEEDS TO BE MEDICATED
AND HOSPITALIZED.
>> TRUMP, AGAIN, BEING A
SCHMUCK.
>> HIS WORDS HAVE EMBOLDENED
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> HE'S GIVEN OXYGEN TO RACIST.
HE'S TRYING TO IGNITE A CIVIL
WAR IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> THERE'S A SIGN OUT THERE HUNG
UP OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING IF YOU'RE NOT WHITE,
YOU'RE NOT ESPECIALLY WELCOME.
>> HE'S A RACIST.
>> BREATH LEST, HYSTERIA,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, FAKE NEWS
STORY AFTER FAKE NEWS STORY.
EVERY MINUTE, HOUR, 24-HOUR DAY,